want to ask another question that's
similar but not about the same ethnic
group there was a big story this week
about a 14 year old Muslim American
teenager in Texas who built a clock he's
a science kid and that's great can we
show the clock okay and the people at
the school thought it might be a bomb
perhaps because it looks exactly like a
[ __ ] bomb and I noticed you know you
were at the debate the a Jake Tapper was
asking you about Isis and important
questions about terrorism and they cut
you off and excuse me governor I have to
talk about a 14 year old who built a
clock and they did and look this kid
deserves an apology no doubt about it
they were wrong but could we have a
little perspective about this did the
teacher really do the wrong thing yeah
can I just go ahead I've talked to the
kid go ahead right he's from Dallas and
I've talked to the people in the school
district the kid is super smart kid
science geek we talked about science but
while I'm talking to him on the phone as
I asked him the question tell me what
happened because I'm curious right his
sister over the over his shoulder you
could hear listening to the question
giving him the answer so I don't know
all the details of what happened but
what I do know when I talked about
science but I talked to him about
magnets where I talked about creating
things he was very very engaged he's a
great kid no he'd kid no one's doubting
that what we're at I'm just asking about
perspective first of all the teacher did
she do she got no no no no okay no but
that part too to all this so I talked up
this is once removed right so I talked
to people in early Texas that worked
with people in MacArthur the school and
I said what happened what did you hear
this is against second hand he said the
kid augment took the clock put it in the
first class teacher said great looks
great it looks great kid picks it up
takes it to the second class she just
said okay whatever it's great it's great
I'm I didn't really comment out from
what I heard takes it to the 3rd class
same thing then he got to a point again
second hand where one of the teachers an
English teacher apparently said look you
got to put it in your backpack because
it's going to make some people nervous
and it's
me nervous and again second he didn't he
wasn't responsive to it okay so it took
six classes right or anything happened
okay not happen if he if he wasn't
muffins controversies precisely because
of the color of his kid I don't not the
color of his skin yes of course it's not
the color of his religion excuse me
somebody looked me in the eye right here
and tell me over the last 30 years if so
many Muslim young Muslim men and he's
young 14 but that's not not never
happened before right hasn't blown a lot
of [ __ ] up around the world and if and
this guy this kid deserves an apology
because he wasn't one of them
but let me read what somebody said on
The Daily Beast Dean Obadiah
said why would a homemade clock get him
arrested you may ask exactly I just
answered that question because for the
last thirty years it's been one culture
that has been blowing [ __ ] up over and
over again I could spend the rest of
this yule I could spit excess well
excuse me but lots of teenagers around
the world have go to join Isis just a
couple in Mississippi a few weeks ago
we're doing it and every time somebody
goes to join Isis everybody around there
says I can't believe it we didn't see it
coming we cannot blame y'all Muslims
around the world know what no but you
had to do was engage with the teacher
and he did it that's the part that was
missing it's not I agree with you right
we're making it a change there's a walk
like a duck to it like it's responsible
when not oh yeah it was wrong you got
arrested but he didn't only to do was
talk to the teacher but it didn't okay
so that's what he wait let me let me let
me read the rest of what this person
said he said he's talking about the fact
that he was from Irving Texas
he said Earvin is only 25 minutes from
Garland where they draw the Prophet
Mohammed contest remember that a few
months was attacked as it was by Isis
sympathizing gunmen in May the message
is clear if you are a Muslim anything
you might might do might anything you do
might be a plot to destroy America no
the message is you can see why they
would err on the side of caution
absolutely
only 25 miles away somebody didn't try
to kill people I can't believe I agree
with you by the way we have zero
tolerance in school for things that are
suspicious and you know right maybe that
doesn't look like a bomb but it doesn't
look like a clock and if I may teach
what if it had a bomb yeah exactly and
so the teacher is supposed to see
something that looks like a bomb and go
oh wait this just might be my white
privilige talking all right
I sure don't want to be politically
incorrect so I'll just let it go
you know what the promise it's kind of
one of the problems we got is this
willingness to take sides in a fight
like this without knowing what the hell
happened and it is amazing everybody
goes right to their battle stations I'm
with the minority they're on our knees
right those teachers are wrong how do
you know if I wasn't there you weren't
there the problem is how do you know
it's all cartoon everything's a [ __ ]
cartoon oh the Liberals can't [ __ ] year
old 14 year old was arrested but we're
doing that liberalize project right
right he should not have been arrested
but he should open his mouth and write
about it he was always dead this is not
if he was arrested and and they took him
off in cuffs and then put him in a cage
and burned him oh no that's Isis he does
that no you know what we arrested we put
a kid after school for a couple of hours
this is not the end of the world but you
know what the end of the world does
happen all over the world
I've general millions of Muslims who are
the victims of other Muslims of their
religion where are the Liberals on this
you know what this is there's a Saudi
who is right now he was arrested same as
Ali Mohammed Al nim are in mni mr and
anna you pronounced that he was arrested
for an anti being at an anti-government
rally a few years ago today he lost his
final legal appeal to not be crucified
so they're going to crucify him crucify
him and then behead him in case the
crucifixion didn't work so if you
haven't used up all your heroism
hashtagging for the clock kid maybe do
it for this guy there he is
[Applause]
you know the last perspective on this
say one thing the teachers said
something that sounds credible they said
he wasn't forthcoming they can't had a
chance to explain himself all you have
to do is explain yourself and for
whatever reasons just shyness we don't
know what it was he wasn't used to that
kind of tension but he didn't explain it
who would have been there to explain
this thing I don't know okay but you
know what the [ __ ] is real quick you
know who the big winner is Ahmed because
when I talk to him sure he got all the
attention
right you know his two hours were taken
but he told me look I've been getting
all these offers I'm not going back to
MacArthur I'm gonna pick which school I
want to go to now because everybody's
offering me scholarships the kid came
out way but but I would love it if one
of the adults who has talked to him
would also say to him you know what what
happened he was wrong but maybe one of
the reasons why it happened to you is
because in our religion we were
responsible for 9/11 the Madrid bombings
the London bombings the Bali discotheque
bombings the Kenya mall bombs he's not
responsible for them he's not of course
not we're not saying he okay we've had
you